[Music]
must be nice news must be nice submitted
by Joe Molly and mailman mm-hmm you get
mailed in your control chair luxe
website claiming to be the Amazon from
millionaires has launched hey what's
doing yeah what is that
it's called hush-hush calm that sounds
like a porn site dude what the [ __ ] yeah
like they're called hush probably maybe
tell me about it
[Laughter]
it's just like ASMR porn sounds like
it's like the most taboo kind of porn no
right dark web [ __ ] yeah box and
dropping scorpions in there yeah I got a
weird [ __ ] like it's directly on her
[ __ ] yeah and then they poked right
around the [ __ ] do you have one of
those crane arms that has to go in and
scoop the scorpions oh there it is
hi Scott that's it count it trading oh
yeah so this website is based in London
and it aims to be a one-stop shop for a
high net worth individual Oh what does
that mean huh gives a [ __ ] international
true I thought millionaires just had
assistance like go get me that which is
Amazon because you know what I always
wondered is like you know what we have
to do the DMV stuff and a normal stuff
like these guys do they don't they get
up what is that called attorneys they
got lawyers doing all that for them we
can't have someone go take a passport
photo for you that you can't maybe you
take the photo and then they send it
telling me Oprah goes to the DMV to take
a photo Chris days where she has the run
special hours for her yeah she's like I
can't do [ __ ] today I am NOT can't stop
it yeah what does Oprah do you know what
I'm saying maybe they they open at like
6:00 a.m. for her to come in by herself
so they have the DMV open just a
government agency they're not opening
the door
they don't give a damn [ __ ] yeah they
don't hush-hush
Oh cuz we can't see it ourselves let's
see let's see what I'm not worth yeah
why can't you you have to be rich to
sign in no you can I mean I am look at
the website also everybody can go on the
website yeah so why is it exclusive
because look at the amount because you
can't afford it you broke [ __ ] 2
million yep 62 British pounds like one
time yeah yeah it's like a like a half
now or some [ __ ] yeah so have it by
categories photos are jewelry watches
fashion huge it's good bye yeah oh my
god jet helicopters it's a gold
Lamborghini you know the guy who started
this site is not a millionaire a hundred
percent this is a great idea this is
what millionaires probably would buy
it's like you don't know you poor [ __ ]
that's why you had this piece of Amazon
it's just a website itself stuff yeah so
they're pretty much trying to be the
middleman between retailers and the
millionaire people so you put it in a
cart like a [ __ ] house donut are you
trying to get to that one person if you
buy a house they'll ship the house to
you start building it yeah
so they will put you in contact with
whoever you need to talk to - oh my god
that is so cool yeah that property is
like all over the world it's so - zoo so
like yeah
I'm feeling to see what new this brings
to the table as far as there are watch
sides there are things like but your
assistance in one place and there's tons
of storage people though I want five
Rolexes yeah get it for me lay in bed
and be like Rolex helicopter I know and
then they show up concierge service
saying like once you check out let's say
you want to buy five Rolexes then you
check out and then a concierge person
will call you to make like verify the
whole purchase and then help you go
through I support people can't
understand what do you guys think about
starting a website called yo hush and
it's Amazon for billionaires crazy [ __ ]
does having a billion dollars is nuts
you got to do some illegal [ __ ] alright
it's like as I come to this country and
then these two guys you could walk on
their shoulders and I mean you could
just stand on their shoulders and there
will be your legs man really still like
human what do you call it that that that
not on the the douche-mobile do you
smell beer Segway yeah that's a Segway
thingy oh the hoverboard Harvard boy
human hoverboard is what they are or
maybe they could be on a hoverboard and
you're just standing on them you guys
not a butler app right have you guys
notice a ladies don't like a ladies app
so you can essentially like going this
app and then pick any man you want to
just be your [ __ ] for the day well they
will like comment like fan you like the
whole band which is a cost or like hair
are you around Oh baby like buff dudes
with just bow ties what are they wearing
like tuxedos when do we just reach to
the point that women don't have to pay
for that yeah there's a difference what
we should not I mean for the most part
it's not quite even women have the
ability to just be like some guy come
Fame but if I want that to happen that's
true for free yeah what if the woman
might be really really really busy and
she's just like I don't want to go
through the filtering process
if you make one story right now they'll
be at least one guy I'll become I'll be
down on the feather have a following if
I didn't have a following yeah what are
you talking about you just walked out
East LA and one cholo would do for you
anyway dude every to do that every check
technically has a following every check
at any given point about the vetting
process yeah they have to be [ __ ] out
crazy
yeah that's true being picky but a
resume for the site knowing I'm willing
to paint toenails maybe you shave a
girl's legs like everything there is a
service in k-town called toe me boys and
told me boys do that for not in that
kind of sense but felt like go karaoke
with these older ladies with a lot of
money and they'll make like [ __ ] like
five grand a weekend so watch old ladies
sing other people's songs yet so
literally wrong business forever I was
told was that these really rich dudes go
sleep this their husbands used their
money to go sleep with hookers
so they're like [ __ ] you I'm gonna use
your money that you give me and I'm
gonna just [ __ ] around with these
other boys the wives of the really just
[ __ ] throw the money at the young
boys and so they just have to walk
around with them you know be their
little arm candy if they want to make
more money they'll make out with them or
some [ __ ]
but you're walking away with like five
grand a [ __ ] dream job if you're a
submissive person you know like an S and
them they have the guys that like to be
like a slave and stuff that's a really
good what you call it profession for
them they could follow their dreams
there's so much stuff like in the whole
S&M thing like there's a it's like
financial bunk how we heard about these
chicks basically like so it's basically
like a guy and his deal is that like he
wants you to harass him and almost
blackmail him for him to send you money
for stuff like that seems like it's like
role-playing no it's kinda it's just
like you just go broke to support this
fetish well [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah like
like you're like look I just need you I
need your credit card information and I
need your bank account and all your
money no just normal just normal jeans
knocking down I got the opposite finish
dude I want a [ __ ] Asian later that
[ __ ] coupon like a [ __ ] did
they just like Oh
she won't let you spend money on stuff
yes just toilet paper is terrible and
she's over there like splitting two-ply
she makes her own rolls she digs in your
trash can and it pulls out ziplock bags
just called fruitless Bobby uses condoms
and [ __ ] it's still good balloons it up
the other side let's watch his car look
I gotta see this [ __ ] what real it is if
you've got a billion bucks like I think
like if I have that type of access to
cash the private jets got to be the best
thing I clicked on helicopters and
they're all these helicopters this one's
like 9 mil oh the cheap one 2 mil but if
you got a billion dollars you could
order a helicopter and be like I don't
like the stitching on that seat and I
join it yeah
where are you telling me about your
billionaire friend that was gonna buy
guns about the yeah yeah yeah he just
straight-up went into like a gun shop
and like ran out of time and like walked
over to the owner and he's like hey uh
do you think like 750 grand would just
cover the inventory and he's like yeah
he's a cool and just wrote him a check
and hazely my guys are gonna come pick
everything up so he bought the whole
store so he was like I'm here to go get
on a jet and Lee a lucky man the guy who
owned this store [ __ ] you planned on
retiring just made 750 oh sure like one
minute that's crazy well I'm not gonna
work for the next three years I would
just turn that open side I just turn it
around leave it that way I was thinking
I could do that like a doughnut shop
would $1,000 take care of
I'll take everything up in this [ __ ]
yeah like I'll take all the donuts all
the gum - I'm taking all the doughnuts
that have holes in them yeah not the
bear claws it's kind of expensive I
can't do that 1 billion dollars the
[ __ ] weird amount of money cuz
everything's essentially free yeah
there's nothing that cost 900 million I
don't want to be that rich do you really
I do
but then sometimes imagining and wishing
it sometimes more it's a lot more fun
than actually getting it but do you
think if you had it right like would you
shop differently because status of the
thing or the price of it wouldn't matter
anymore like that wouldn't be the part
that turned you on you'd only buy the
[ __ ] that you like exactly I know what I
want
yeah the elements very [ __ ] seven of
them did I'm gonna be building
playgrounds a piece of [ __ ]
yeah playgrounds like not to attract
children no it's my playground new
website they're just private Nam you
guys could come but now you guys can
come you all get like a key card in the
different places saying how crazy fun
well I mean like my kind of playground
is like we'll have one you know it's
like it's like a paintball kind of area
but it's not paintball just we could
shoot all kinds of [ __ ] like I'll have
zip lines and whatever [ __ ] just I
guess it's like a training facility if
you think about it I'll have one for
that I'll have one that is every [ __ ]
age like we got freaking Stone Age
Bronze Age Iron Age like we're gonna
build [ __ ] mud huts for the primitive
age and I'm just gonna hire actors for
every single era you're gonna [ __ ]
live there and chill is this the first
time you do
it's very thought out I imagine but I
just would never go to an airport it's
like a red that's all but like different
age and you could go to sleep what in
one of these Hut's are like a castle
whenever you want whatever what era do
you want to sleep in that's my question
[Music]
[Applause]